hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll some
of you may know that one of the bonuses
of my new job here at Johns Hopkins is
that I got to choose my own title I mean
my title is Homewood Professor but then
Homewood professor of what and I got to
choose what that is knowing that I would
both be involved in the physics
department and the philosophy Department
I thought it would be fun to call myself
a professor of natural philosophy those
of you who know realize that back in the
day before we had separated out
something called science and something
called physics from philosophy people
like Isaac Newton or Galileo would have
been considered to be philosophers
Newton famously wrote his principia
Mathematica right principles of
mathematics but it's actually
mathematical principles of natural
philosophy that is the full title of the
book and that would have been you know
their labels and I like that idea
because I think that philosophy and
physics there's a certain kind of
philosophy in a certain kind of physics
that really really overlap that are
almost indistinguishable from each other
asking the biggest questions about what
is the world what is it made of where
did it come from why does it exist those
kinds of things that really intersect
with more down-to-earth physics
questions like how does Quantum
Mechanics Work what is fine-tuning in
cosmology things like that and there's a
set of people it's certainly not just me
I didn't invent anything here but
there's a set of people who actively
work in exactly these kinds of questions
we've had several of them on the podcast
already Janine Ismail David Wallace
David Albert and we have another one
today Barry lower who is friends with
all these people you know we all hang
out Etc there's more of them that I'm
going to be bringing on as as time goes
on what I like about Barry in particular
is that he is absolutely well versed in
modern physics and how it thinks about
quantum mechanics relativity what have
you but he came up as a philosopher
right as opposed to you know David
Albert or David Wallace who actually got
their phds in physics before realizing
that the kinds of physics they were
doing were heavily philosophical Barry
was there as a philosopher from the
start and became interested in physics
and what we're going to talk about is
truly philosophical questions like what
is a law right what is a law of physics
what does it mean to talk about other
possible worlds David Lewis was the
famous philosopher who really put the
idea of possible worlds front and center
in the philosophical imagination how
does causality work in the real world
Barry along with David Albert has been
championing an idea called the metaculus
the idea of a probability map of the
universe with the name stolen from
McCullen Brothers movie so we'll talk
about that also how do you go from
physics to the metaculus the probability
map of everything that can happen in the
world and from there start talking about
human-sized things the special Sciences
as they are called is their Free Will
can we talk about human beings in a
scientific way although those kinds of
things it's a great great example of an
intersection of real science real
philosophy and Barry is a really good
person at explaining some of these
esoteric ideas so let's go
[Music]
very lower welcome to the mindscape
podcast hi Sean so this is something
where we'll cover a lot of ground that I
think mindscape listeners have been
exposed to before whether it's the arrow
of time or causality or things like that
but I thought we could start at the
widest possible view just to really give
an impression of how dramatic what we're
talking about here is you know on the
one hand you want to talk about you want
to reach the special Sciences as they're
called right why there is a discussion
of things like psychology or sociology
or political science or economics but on
the other hand we're starting with
statistical mechanics you know the stuff
that was invented in the 1800s by
boltzmann and Maxwell and those people
like Am I Wrong to think this is quite a
dramatic and long journey and we should
be uh impressed that we can try to make
these connections
not wrong at all I think it's incredibly
astonishing and one of the Amazing
Discoveries that uh statistical
mechanics is at the root of all the
special sciences and causation and the
era of time and much else and is this
something where you know the philosopher
on the street who is interested in these
areas basically buys into that statement
you just made or are you fighting an
uphill battle as a Plucky minority
well my street doesn't have many
philosophers on it I live downtown
Manhattan but
um uh I think it's a new idea I mean the
way it's gotten somewhat into the
community is via
um a book by David Albert that was
published about 20 something years ago
in your book on uh from eternity to here
I think these are the main sources for
me I studied statistical mechanics in
college but I didn't have an inkling
that it was going to be so important
philosophically not an inkling at all in
fact the only way it came up in
philosophy was over the issue of
reduction and discussions of how
thermodynamics gets reduced to uh
statistical mechanics so it was supposed
to be the Paradigm of reducibility right
but it's an enormous importance from my
view it it's more important than
anything else in physics to philosophy
good I'm not going to disagree with that
so uh so then in that case let's get
into it and thought that the the entry
point given other things we've talked
about in the podcast uh might just be
the very idea of counter factual talking
right I mean it seems that we can't in
our everyday lives get through the day
without talking about how things could
have been different uh and as a
philosopher I I think that you're going
to tell us this brings in a lot of
baggage and assumptions I mean what does
it mean when we talk about if this had
not happened then something else would
have been the case
well I think the sort of the origin of
kind of factual thinking is actually
somewhat is what you might think of a
subjunctive thinking about how we're
going to act so we're interested in what
would happen if I were to do this or to
do that and then that gets extended to
think about what would have happened
were I to have done this or that and
then that's got extended to what would
have happened were this to have occurred
or that to have occurred and it turns
out that this way of talking has been
enormously useful as a way of talking
about what actually happens what really
is is just what actually happens and
subjunctive or kind of factual thinking
is just a complicated way we've
developed human beings have developed in
order to talk about what actually
happens
okay uh maybe just say more directly
about that like why do I need to talk
about things that didn't happen in order
to talk about what actually happened is
it just more clarifying for me or is it
kind of crucial uh that's a good
question I I think I would answer that I
think in two ways one is that what we're
really doing when introducing certain
Notions into scientific language
like counter factuals or probability is
we're providing a way of sim simplifying
to talk about complicated actual events
that's one part but of course also it's
very natural for us to just imagine how
things go one way or the other so
imagination is going to be very Central
in them and
important and how these two fit together
is a good question that I have to admit
I haven't thought about it so I'm glad
you asked the question all right good we
like to spawn new research programs here
on on the podcast uh but okay but
clearly one related closely related
concept here is that of causality right
cause and effect we I recently did a
podcast with Judea Pearl who is a big
name in causal reasoning these days and
I mean maybe I heard it it was great oh
good good good
um maybe put into your words how you
think about the relationship between
causality which I would I bet seems to
most people on the street as something
that is here in our world and its
relationship to counterfactual reasoning
like in some sense it needs to be a
comparison between the actual and the
non-actual well of course we all somehow
acquire a notion of causation it may be
it's even in some way innate that we
have some sort of concept like that and
we mostly connect it to things that we
feel deal with the Motions of our bodies
but we extend it beyond that to think
about what would were to happen were we
to move our bodies one way or or another
and
um there's a close connection then
between causation and counter factuals
I'm not saying that you can literally
say what it is for one event to cause
another just in terms of counter
factuals have been attempts as you know
by David Lewis and others to just
characterize causation in terms of
counter factuals other attempts to
characterize causation in terms of
probabilistic relations
I think these are going to be closely
connected to each other I don't think
anybody has really ever worked it out
just how they're closely connected to it
another research part program that I'm
interested in in the background of this
I always have in mind Bertrand Russell's
famous remark let's see how does it go
that the concept of causation is like
the British Monarchy I guess the British
Monarchy has just celebrated what it's
75th of a birthday of its current
Incarnation uh Russell thought that like
the British Monarchy it uh it's as
useless as the British modern exactly
yeah and should be dispensed with well
the British Monarchy hasn't been
dispensed with and despite Russell's
remark causation hasn't been dispensed I
don't think it can be on the other hand
I'm not sure that anything exactly
corresponding to our notion of causation
will be found in reality just something
that does this work of course so we can
understand why it is that we we can talk
about causation even if we don't find
literally some causation I think a lot
of our ordinary concepts are like that
and something that philosophers need to
pick up on uh free will as another
example we'll certainly get to free will
uh near the end but I mean maybe this is
actually a point worth highlighting
because I think that a lot of people
have in mind uh that they use again
people who are not experts in these
fields think about cause and effect as
just law-like Behavior right and and
you're trying to draw a distinction
between fundamental physics where there
is law-like behavior but not of the
cause and effect variety that's what
Russell had in mind and this higher
level emergent World in which we live
where you need to talk in terms of
causes and effects
yes I mean that's that's right and um
the way I like to think about it is
something I learned when I was I guess
even an undergraduate uh you probably
know this but it's a very famous
philosophical essay by Wilfred Sellers
and I forget what it's called even right
now but in which he introduces the terms
manifest image and scientific image and
I think that one of the main jobs of
philosophers is to show how to fit
together this our manifest image how the
world
appears to us in our ordinary way of
thinking about it it's a sort of a
biological and psychological endowment
developed by culture with what science
has discovered that the world is like by
applying scientific methodology and
discovering laws and so on all right
sounds like a good thing to be able to
do so um you mentioned David Lewis
famously he uh thought a lot about
possible worlds so this is you know the
typical or the good philosopher move
when you have an idea like
counterfactual reasoning and try to
think through what is really going on
in some sense when you say if this had
not happened this would have happened
you're you're invoking the concept
anyway of a whole nother possible world
and Lewis took those Concepts really
really seriously
I think Lewis has often misunderstood
okay I don't want to say that you're one
who's misunderstanding him but let's see
how this goes sure yeah maybe it's me
who misunderstands him but I've spent a
lot of my life thinking about David
Lewis I knew him but I wasn't a student
of his and for me
uh if I can say it's a preamble I was at
a party of philosophers those are the
only kind of parties that will invite me
a few weeks ago which a bunch of
philosophers talking and I heard him
using the talking one of the people that
was talking about someone they called
the philosopher and at first I thought
they were talking about Aristotle but no
they were talking about David Lewis
pretty good all right and right for
contemporary philosophers of my ilk
David Lewis is the greatest philosopher
of the 20th century it may be of all
time in many ways although
one could argue about what one thinks
philosophy is in that I don't want to
get into an argument about that but in
any case Lewis was really interested in
actuality what happens in the actual
world but what he thought is that in
order to talk about the actual world you
have in a in a good way in a simple way
uh in a convenient way we need to
introduce the notion of possible world
but then he realized that if we're going
to really take this talk seriously he
followed his teacher Quine often think
of Quine and Lewis as being very
different but in fact they're very close
to each other
uh equine was Lewis's dissertation
advisor he followed Quine in thinking
that he if he's going to talk about
counter factuals using possible World
semantics to make sense of kind of
factuals even though ultimately what
makes a kind of factual true or false is
just what's going on in the actual world
we could come back to how that's
supposed to work maybe
um he's going to have to take the notion
of possible World seriously so he asked
the question what are possible worlds
and he came up with a particular view
about it many philosophers saw his view
about that and they thought well Lewis
he's a great guy he's really smart but
he must be out of his blank weeping mind
and they greeted him with what he calls
an incredulous stare
I have a very different view I think
when you really understand what he
thinks possible worlds are and you think
about the rest of his philosophy
although I don't buy it it's not for
that reason
it's
um it makes a lot of sense given the
rest of what's going on a lot of which
many other people would accept
okay so I I think you can make good
sense of it but this may be a discussion
that's more for the the I don't know the
in-house philosopher than the one you
want to get into well it may be but but
let's just sort of summarize I think
what what is going on for everybody else
the typical view of Lewis is that he
really thought all the other possible
worlds were just as real as ours and and
you're saying that's not quite what he
thought
he did think that okay we understand
real correctly
but he also thought what they really are
are just geometries with real with
space-time points which are decorated by
what with what he called Perfectly
Natural properties
when you really understand that and you
think you really need this notion of
Perfectly Natural property to make sense
of everything else in science as Lewis
did I don't but Lewis did then this idea
of possible worlds gets reduced into the
notion of possible geometry
which is a math it's almost a
mathematical notion because you do need
something like space time points and
he's got to take them in some senses
real but then not real in the sense that
you can you can get from this anything
any point in this world to any point in
any other world there's no distance
relations between them right okay but
they're real enough and then they're
decorated with real Perfectly Natural
properties just as real as the Perfectly
Natural properties that decorate the
actual world is there anything special
about the actual world yeah of course
it's really special it's where we are
good and we're special I'll take that as
an answer but okay so
um let's hope in that's Lewis's answer
that's fine I I honestly do accept that
um and Lewis had this idea that not only
well I mean maybe we're glossing over
this for people who haven't listened to
the Judea Pearl podcast
um
when we try to understand causality in
the language of possible worlds so we're
saying that something like
X causes y means in the possible worlds
where X didn't happen y didn't happen
and then all there's a lot of work
trying to clean that up yeah yes that's
the semantics
but what makes the statement true or
false
the statement that the throwing of the
brick caused the breaking of the window
what makes that true or false are just
events that happen in the actual World
sure events which can be described
without bringing in the notion of
causation or law at all so for Lewis
what there is fundamentally is just
space-time points and Perfectly Natural
properties instantiated at various
space-time points think about it as kind
of like a big field
this the points with space-time with
Perfectly Natural properties
instantiated
about the world is made true or false
including whether or not the brick broke
the window because the window to break
or whether or not you or I are talking
right now whether or not my cat is
purring or anything else that's an
astonishing claim that is astonishing
that should be greeted with an
incredulous stare until you see all the
work that Lewis did to make it plausible
wait sorry say what the claim is that is
incredible that is astonishing claim is
here's the here's the Philosopher's way
of putting it all the truths about the
world super being on the distribution of
Perfectly Natural properties throughout
all of space and time okay that is say
the distribution of Perfectly Natural
properties at all space and time make
true or false every Claim about the
world good and the philosophical fun
comes in because someone says
the reason why the window broke is
because the brick got thrown through it
and someone else says oh that means if
the brick hadn't been thrown the window
wouldn't have broken and then someone
else says oh but there was another brick
that was being thrown at the window also
so the window would have broken anyway
even in that other possible world and
you have to be clever about saying which
worlds you're comparing right yes that's
a problem with causation in particular
that has to do with preemption or or
there's another related over
determination issue I think that's one
of the problems that Lewis struggled
with and I think one of your other
friend of mine who get did a podcast
with I don't remember whether you talked
about it's Ned Hall uh has written quite
a bit about that also and and I I my own
view is I should say is I haven't really
grappled with that enough but lest I
looked I didn't think it was fully
worked out okay but but it brings up I
mean Lewis in trying to tackle problems
like that and there's other problems
maybe you can tell us what some of them
are but he introduced this notion of
similar worlds right like how do you
compare one world to another and and I I
still don't know what that's supposed to
mean how do I know whether a different
world is similar to mine is there some
distance measure that tells me how
different worlds are great question
which is why I think while Lewis is a
account of so the notion of counter fact
can I back up a little bit and think
about kind of factuals so the the idea
of talking about counter factuals among
philosophers well it goes way back David
um
a characterize Equalization can terms of
count of factuals but there wasn't a
really a focused discussion of it until
Nelson Goodman in the late 40s and
Goodman said this he gave his example
was if I had struck the match it would
have lit and Goodman says well what does
that mean well that means if
um uh uh here's the situation the match
wasn't struck but now Matt think of a
situation the match is struck
and otherwise the situation was the same
as it actually was
and the laws does that entail that the
match strikes but what does it mean the
situation was exactly it was it couldn't
be exactly it was because the match
wasn't struck so what he meant was the
circumstances the conditions had to be
the same well what does that mean he
called those conditions that were the
same he called them cotenable with the
matches being struck
but not every condition that actually
holds its cotenable so for example you
might have someone who would only strike
a match if the match is wet
in that case the match is being dry
would not be cotenable in which case it
wouldn't light so now you have to say
what does cotenable mean what David
Lewis did was to get rid of the notion
of cotenability and exchange it for the
notion of similarity
and then thereby produce a much more
general account
I think this is all a big mistake
I don't know if you want to follow up
the why it's mistake I think everything
could be done in terms of probabilities
and all those probabilities come from
where we started from statistical
mechanics yeah no that is where I want
to go but you know it is fun to sort of
sift through the mistakes along the way
because I mean I'm not going to be cagey
about this I can remember my whole
bleeping career to do it right
I'm completely on board with where we're
going to end up so I I want to cherish
the mistakes along the way I mean when
we do compare worlds to each other one
way or another you know our world is
thought of it by physicists as described
by some initial conditions and then some
laws of physics that tell you where you
go from those initial conditions So when
you say something like the match wasn't
struck I could imagine either that I
change the initial conditions in such a
way that the world looks really really
similar except the match doesn't get
stricken
or that just the laws of physics were
temporarily violated in that particular
striking of the match and so they didn't
follow from the initial conditions is
there some preference for one of these
over the other so Lewis did the second
that was a big mistake in my view right
my preference is keep the laws the same
under any kind of factual condition
that's condition that's consistent with
the laws not necessarily consistent with
those being the laws but consistent with
the content of the laws
and that's the view about kind of
counter factuals that I've developed
right okay good so we're it certainly
again it makes sense to me as a
physicist to change the initial
conditions a little bit that doesn't
change very much that it doesn't do
violence to our system but changing the
laws of physics even temporarily just
seems bad to me
it's bad for many reasons here's one
reason it's bad if it were the case as
Lewis thinks that if I had struck the
match when I didn't would require there
to be a violation of the laws
fundamental laws of physics before
the Striking was supposed to take place
then it should also be true that if I
had struck the match I should have won
the Nobel Prize for physics right why
all right we're falsified the laws of
quantum mechanics
surely that deserves a Nobel Prize yes
good and and the good news just to
anticipate to foreshadow a little bit is
you don't have to imagine that I mean
you can have this conversation without
ever violating laws of physics right yes
good
um so what is a law of physics well of
course that's the question that mainly
fuels what I'm interested in I'm writing
a whole book about trying to figure out
what that is the way I like to put it I
hope you don't mind my repeating a
little slogan I like is that while it's
the job of physicists to tell us what
laws there are it's the job of
philosophers to tell us what laws are
I like I don't know who deserves bigger
salaries but
physicists have made a lot more progress
than philosophers have on their question
um there are a lot of different views
about what laws are
they go way back to when the notion of
flow is introduced in the 17th century
while there's some notion like that
going way back to the Greeks it really
wasn't clear that this is what is going
on in physics that what should be
searched for is mathematical laws that
describe how things move around until
sometime in the 17th century in fact the
philosopher who enunciated this is a
program is one of the main people that's
all philosophary undergraduates read is
Descartes but in a book that isn't read
very much called lemons and in that book
he literally says something like it's
the job of us guys by which he met both
philosophers and physicists since they
didn't make a distinction in those days
I see now have given you a new position
that we're coming back to this
situation now which I think is good
um that uh
um uh this is what should be done we
should be finding what laws are and he
had an idea about what laws are can I
say what he thought laws were please
yeah
okay what you thought was were is
something that would might surprise many
current physicists you tell me whether
you to go to your physics colleagues to
tell them tell them what what what what
they call it and Newton for that matter
thought laws were
Newton literally says that one of his
henchmen says that what laws are are
God's revolutions
somehow yeah theological origin to the
notion of law when it was introduced in
the 17th it's Century of course that's
been falling apart another project not
for me but for a historian of science so
if there's any historian of science
who's listening to our podcasts maybe
one of them connect this up because
nobody has done this there is no book
length study of the history of the
concept of fundamental laws of physics
or the special Sciences if there are
Elizabeth and special Sciences one thing
has happened is the notion of the
theological part has kind of Fallen
apart away in which case the question
arises well if laws aren't God's
volitions what are they
okay well so what's the answer
okay so I think there the number of
ideas that people have given of answers
some I'm going to back up a teeny bit
one idea is just to find a replacement
for God good something that does God's
work what was God doing he was pushing
things around so some philosophers
um introduce something into the world
which pushed things around
one philosopher did that was David
Armstrong who put this this question
really clearly on the table of
philosophers about 1979 or 80 in a book
he wrote called what is the law of
nature he thought that laws were extra
things facts outside of the ordinary
facts which necessitate the facts that
happen
the way he did it was very very in it in
congress with the way physicists
actually talk about laws I won't get
into details about wow a philosopher
who's done it in a way along the same
lines but in a way much better because
he's a very sophisticated philosopher of
physics is my friend Tim Maudlin so Tim
has the idea that what laws are are
elements of the fundamental reality
ontological if that if you don't mind
that there anyway they're in reality and
they do something they produce or govern
by taking the state of the world at a
time
and making this state at the next time
or nearby times
that's moreland's idea it's an
interesting and influential idea my idea
is not like that at all I want to get
rid of God not because I'm a
non-believer that's not the reason I
just don't think we need God to do this
work right so in what that means in
practice is that this idea of sort of
guiding or pushing it was the false step
that people made yeah I should very
quickly mention I doubt that Tim will
listen to this but if he does I should
mention that whenever I bring up the
theological origin I want to do it
making sure he's not in the room because
he wants to kill me
but I do think it's a it's a reasonable
point to bring up because many of the
intuitions that we still have about laws
and including the language that we use
to talk about laws like governing
reflect this and I think it prevents us
from accepting what I think is a much
better view right which I can now go on
and describe to you that much better
view derives
unsurprisingly from the philosopher
David Lewis okay
well Lewis said he took this idea from
John Stewart Mill and from Frank Ramsey
was an important mathematician
philosopher in the first part of the
20th century he said look what
physicists are interested is in
describing all the facts that will hold
throughout all space and time
we want to have a way of describing them
all which is it somehow makes them
accessible to us
what accessible means there requires
much more discussion than a given right
now I can give it
um but it has to be simple
tell us a lot about them it has to be
simple Lewis called this the best
systematization of the fundamental facts
as I said earlier for Lewis the
fundamental facts were just the
distribution of Perfectly Natural
properties throughout all of space and
time
so what you want is an axiom system
which will best balance
informativeness giving us as much
information as one can about all those
facts in a simple way as it can and
maybe it has satisfied other features
too that make them accessible and
important important for giving
scientific explanations and so on and
something you mentioned earlier is very
fits into this very well because
dividing
the facts up into initial conditions and
General
Dynamics the way initial conditions
um evolve over time
turns out to be a way of doing that for
a world like ours didn't have to be this
is a con a contingent feature nature of
our world but it seems to be so for our
world
and and so I mean let's let's give our
listeners some jargon to hold on to is
this the human versus anti-human
distinction yes the the God view
remember scare quotes around Gods I
don't cause problems for myself uh is
the anti-union view
Lewis is the union view my own view is a
develop I'm not going to get into it
unless you ask me but it's kind of like
Lewis's but does away with a lot of
Lewis's baggage and makes it much more
fit in with contemporary physics
but that may be more than we want to get
into for right now when I talked to Ned
Hall on the podcast I brought up the
fact that there was a name associated
with the human view namely David Hume
but no name associated with the
anti-human view so maybe we should just
call it the God view I think that that
would be perfectly acceptable oh well
call it that or the modeling view but
they'll call it both all right
another a couple of people I should get
this in who hold the view why some of
you know uh on the anti-union part we've
just gave an interesting talk and
written a paper about it is my former
student Eddie Shannon and my colleague
Shelly Goldstein uh so Eddie you
probably know from he's made a giant
Splash in the philosophy of physics
community and Shelley is of course
famous for being the main uh I don't
know what to say promulgator of bomian
mechanics yeah yep all right there are
people out there who are uh anti-human
the God's eye view but the humans which
among which I count myself
um they're saying that the laws aren't
governing anything they're just
descriptions right is that too
simplistic
well they're not just descriptions
you know that's like calling I don't
know
the queen Just Another Woman it's not
like that they're very special
descriptions they're descriptions which
both combine they come from a
systematization that combines Simplicity
and informativeness and other features
important explanation in the in in an
optimal way right fair enough they're
very very special descriptions of what
happens but at some level amazing is
there's no other junk in the world
there's no other other than the ordinary
facts right there's the facts and and
that is what makes up the world and so
that's the whole fact about the facts
right nothing but the facts but there's
two questions that that even though I'm
on this side I really do struggle with
one is if
what we think of as the laws are sort of
exposed facto there's the world and all
the facts and then we sort of abstract
the laws from them why are there laws
why is the world so regular and
predictable I mean we can easily imagine
any set of things happening in the world
an ex post facto look for simple
descriptions thereof but we have really
special things going on right that's a
great great question if I thought it was
going to come up I should have I would
have had it ready a quote from Einstein
who asks himself that question
and he just I I don't remember the quote
exactly it's a pretty well known quote
someone could find it in which he says
something to the effect of it's awesome
but it doesn't lead him to believe that
the world has been made this way by God
and it certainly won't help to posit
some extra what force that makes it like
that because that just raises the
question again where does that Force
come from so okay so what he does says
is the only thing you could do
is being awe and I do think that's a
good State of Mind to be in a lot of the
time for philosopher or a physicist I
guess okay so I I mean I'm willing to
sort of tentatively accept that but I do
think it's a a little bit of a point for
the opposite side right I mean if you
think okay
what is the opposite side their
philosophers have written papers some of
them are quite good uh uh arguing that
and I have a section of this book I'm
writing trying to rebut them so I'm not
saying that it's totally closed matter I
I get the pull of it but I just don't
see how positing us something else as
long as it's literally a scientific
posit that's supposed to make things
happen gets you any place because the
same kind of question arises about
whatever it is that you posited okay no
I think that that's perfectly fair and
it is like it or not it is very similar
and analogous to discussions about God
where they have a feature of the world
and a theist will say I can explain this
feature of the World by invoking God but
then you haven't explained you know
where God came from and the laws of
physics are in an analogous situation
here if you count them as something
extra right yeah so Einstein's point I
think in this quote was some people
satisfy their religious impulse by just
is saying God they're going to church
others satisfy it by just being in awe
and our son was preferring the second of
those good okay I go with that all right
so yeah I mean just like why is there
something rather than nothing there's
some features of reality for which it's
there's no deeper explanation it's
something that is you know what Sydney
Morgan investor said about that question
I do but tell the teller listeners
okay Sydney morgenbusters said is that
well even it was there was nothing you
would still complain about it it's it's
very it's very apt so okay if I accept
that there's the other slightly more
down to earth question for the human
view which is
how do we think about counter factuals
you know it if I think about the laws of
physics as summarizing what happens in
the world the facts of the world then
how can I extend them to other worlds
where those other worlds have their
other facts and therefore other laws in
some sense well that's a really good
question and I try to deal with that too
um I I would say that there's a deeper
question that has bothered philosophers
has written a bit about is explanation
because if laws are just inscriptions
how can they explain but of course this
is closely connected to your question
let me deal with your question for a
minute
um remember what you're saying about
counter factuals before on Lewis's view
counter factors are made true or false
just by the actual facts
that's it okay turns out that the way
the laws are is they invite they invite
this description this distinction
between initial conditions and dynamical
principles which say how initial
conditions evolve this fits very much in
with the way we're thinking about
counter factuals and so what we do in
kind of factuals we say well under these
alternative conditions
how will the dynamical laws say that
things evolve and the reason we do that
goes back to a point also made earlier
in the discussion and that is counter
Factor was introduced for us to say
about what would happen where we were I
to make various decisions one things I
know that when I make various decisions
all that I effect is some little part of
my brain or mind
I don't affect what's going on at the
same time around me maybe I don't affect
anything that I know about in the past
maybe we'll come back to that
um I can influence what happens in the
future
if we understand influence properly yeah
I don't influence the law so I keep the
laws fixed when I vow to evaluate
Counting factuals
I think that you mean account can
provide an explanation about why you
keep the laws fixed because the union
account by the by emphasizing
informativeness and simplicity
leads in a world like Arts at a division
between initial conditions and dynamical
principles
we know that the most we can do is to
make a little influence on certain
initial certain parts of the initial
conditions at a moment
and keeping everything else fixed we
then say what would happen next and to
come back to our original where we got
into this discussion turns out that
statistical mechanics is the key to
answering all that so let me just
rephrase it to see if I got it correctly
because again I think I think I want the
same wavelength even though the human
doesn't think of the laws as extra
ontological entities that are governing
anything we can still figure out what
the laws are and then it's perfectly
sensible to ask what would a
counterfactual possible world look like
with the same laws but slightly
different conditions
yes I mean you asked that you brought up
a slightly different issue and that is
figuring out there is a question about
the epistemology of laws how we find out
about laws okay but we somehow have good
guesses as to what the laws are we can
could talk about that once we do that
we well we we of course most people
don't know in much physics so they don't
go back to the fundamental physical laws
to figure out kind of factuals they just
come up with generalizations about their
world which ultimately made true or
false by the fundamental laws of physics
and the conditions in our world and they
use those generalizations to evaluate
kind of factual and figure out what
would happen were they to throw a brick
at a certain kind of window or or jump
off a uh a building or whatever good so
it really it does hang together I think
in a in a decent way but you brought up
the issue of explanation which is one
that I've not thought about at all
really uh other than in Trivial ways so
what should I want to move on to other
things but what should people have in
mind about what needs to be explained
about explanation
okay so let me let me play the The
Devil's Advocate right although I don't
know why anybody would want to play the
devil because everybody's supposedly
responsible for
um so here's the objection
the objection was made very very clearly
by the model I mentioned before another
philosopher named Mark Lang makes his
objection very clearly and so on but
many other people have too and that is
to say this look if as you yumians say
laws are just descriptions
and the descriptions of the ordinary
facts and the ordinary facts make the
laws obtain how can the laws explain
anything aren't you just running in a
circle yeah that's the objection
it definitely has a pull
but think about it for a minute or I
thought about it for more than a minute
when you think about it
what's going on there is that I think
what they're doing is making use of
their anti-umion what you call God view
about laws as producing events if you
think about laws like that then of
course you're screwed because you can't
have both the fundamental facts that are
producing the laws and the laws
producing the ordinary facts but the
union doesn't think about the laws is
producing facts in fact the main Union
reason for being anti-union is that when
you when asked how do the laws produce
facts
the anti-union says beats me I have no
idea what are these things outside of
the world doing to make for a fact
they're just employing our ordinary
Notions of causation and using as though
they understand and applying that we
don't okay I think okay so I think the
right way to think about laws is not as
produ explaining by producing they
explain mostly by unifying what the laws
do is they unify okay with the best
systematization does is it finds the
patterns in the world which fit together
in various ways in terms of Concepts
which human beings
have used to develop because we're human
beings there's certain Concepts that we
have because of our biological nature
psychological and cultural nature so
that certain similarities are very
important to us
okay obviously it's important you know I
don't know who who the people of
different genders are or whatever you
might think where the food is and so on
so we make certain similarities but of
course there's nothing from physics
point of view that makes anything more
similar than another as far as physics
is concerned okay that just the initial
conditions okay so good so that I don't
want to dive in too far into that but
that does make sense to me uh but you
brought up once again this issue of
causation and now I think that we have
enough on the ground to get into where
Lewis might not have gotten it right
about causation because you know one of
the fundamental features of causation
that we all know is that causes precede
effects they come before the effects in
time or depending on what kind of
Clauses you're talking about maybe
they're simultaneous or something like
that but we don't say that the uh the
brick was thrown because the window was
going to break right that's not a
formation we would ever do so how can
statistical mechanics I know that I know
the answer to this question but you can
you can say it in your own words how can
statistical mechanics help us understand
why it causes precede effects
I will answer that but first I should
say that Lewis thought that he had an
answer to that question right he thought
his answer to that question was it's
going it's because of the nature of our
world that it's that's much smaller
violations of law would be required to
get a Divergence from the actual
situation prior to an event than to
afterwards to get a convergence to the
actual world
and he had an inkling that the reason to
for that had something to do with
statistical mechanics he just didn't
know how he does this in a paper of his
called times arrow and counter factual
dependence from my money it's one of the
great papers of 20th century philosophy
even though
it's full of for my many errors I only
know that there are errors because I've
thought a lot about that paper okay yeah
or I think there are you so that okay
all right
what statistical mechanics does and like
you said I mean I I'd learned this in
part from talking to David Albert I I
have to admit that this is before I read
your book but I also learned it from
teaching your book to students and so on
that the fundamental dynamical laws of
the world are temporally symmetrical in
an important way
okay you got to be careful if you want
to please physicist us about this but
the important way is that any
macroscopic sequence of events that are
compatible to laws that can happen in
one temporal Direction can happen in the
opposite temporal Direction
that's true for all the physics we've
ever had anything to do with why
do we never see ice cubes forming
spontaneously out of water but we only
see it was melting why do we only see
people growing old smoke dispersing and
so on and so on and so on
and the answer to that as I of course
you know and which is I think most
beautifully if you don't mind my
complimenting your return do not mind
about this is expressed in the best way
I know in your book that's why I teach
from it it comes from statistical
mechanics it's because boltzmann
originally discovered that since
material objects and macroscopic objects
are made up out of many many many many
many many parts with many many degrees
of freedom very high number 10 to the 20
something degrees of freedom more than
that really
um uh
and they're moving around in some way
that he wants to describe as random we
can come back to what that means in just
a second but hope we have time for that
because that's for somebody that could a
graph in this whole thing for me
is um it turns out that if you're in a
situation in which the Ice Cube
is sitting there
in warm water
it's very very likely that those random
motions will lead to that ice cube being
more melted in the future
okay and that's why the Ice Cube melts
unfortunately for boltzmann has pointed
out by I think his teacher locksmith it
turns out that if you use the same
reasoning it's also more likely that the
Ice Cube was smaller in the past yeah
and so that it did form spontaneously
out of the water how are you going to
deal with that here's where the new
where the idea came in which I think is
only become
sort of accepted I'm not sure you can
tell me whether this is a consensus I
was just being asked by a student
recently whether it's a consensus now
but I know the idea was sort of
suggested by boltzmann in a funny way
later uh um Eddington suggests that
Feynman presents it
David Albert given a name he calls it
the past hypothesis you not only give a
name to it you try to find an
explanation for why it holds and it's
the claim that you look you can answer
this question once and for all about the
whole universe by saying that the whole
universe very at the time we think of
around the Big Bang at that time the
so-called entropy of the universe was
very very very tiny that means that in a
certain sense the degrees of there are
many fewer in a certain sense of fewer
uh ways in which the constituents of the
universe
were arranged
um uh moving around then then they could
have been which makes it given the
random motion much likely that they will
evolve in such a way so that they get
into ways of higher entropy and this
explains why the so-called second law of
Thermodynamics that the entropy of any
system in the universe isolated system
and the intribute universe increases
over time it explains it but only by
modifying it slightly by adding very
very likely will increase over time yeah
I I'm not sure whether that's a
consensus or not I think that uh 10 or
12 years ago when I started talking
about this or 20 years ago even I'm
getting older uh it was certainly not a
consensus but not because people didn't
believe it it's because they hadn't
thought about it in the physics
Community right like they just hadn't
thought very clearly about these
questions uh and so I did get a lot of
pushback saying no you just you just
don't understand statistical mechanics
at all I think today I would get less
pushback but people aren't going to say
they change their minds they're just
going to sort of have absorbed that
little bit of wisdom
all along so I I'm puzzled Feynman
definitely has this view yeah Feynman
was an important guy Why didn't it
spread from Feynman to others he must
have told others about it
no I mean it's right there in the
Feynman lectures it's there in the uh
character of physical law and no one
paid attention yeah it's really it's
really a star vitamin is very explicit
about hating philosophers there's a lot
of self-hate in that
I always say like you can't not do
philosophy of physics you can only do it
badly but uh he is actually pretty good
at it except for his explicit statements
about it so yeah so Feynman like you
said Eddington even boltzmann suggested
it as one of the possible things that we
begin in a state of low entropy we call
that the past hypothesis
um
right exactly
um and then just one little clarifying
technical Point here when we have this
discussion at all are we thinking the
back of our minds classically like
deterministically like there's some
atoms bumping into each other or do
things importantly change if we take
quantum mechanics seriously so I would
say the the best answer I could give is
while I understand quantum mechanics
pretty well I've studied it and I've
written about the philosophy of quantum
mechanics I don't fully
understand enough about what Quantum
field Theory 2 will look like once it
gets combined with gravity yeah
um and people have made various
proposals about that so I can't say that
things won't change but so far as I can
understand things now I'd be interested
very interested to know what you and
others think about this that it won't
make no difference
well I think it's interesting because I
also suspect it will make no difference
except that if you're one when you're
thinking classically you have to do more
work I think because you have to imagine
that there's a deterministic map from
the early conditions to today and
there's a lot of information containing
what's going on today and so I don't
think it has to be deterministic the
fundamental laws could be
indeterministic even classically I mean
they're not but they could have been
well they could have and you'd get the
same kind of arguments going no that's
true I guess all I'm saying is that uh
quantum mechanics because we'll get into
this later a little bit also but there
is some Randomness at least seen by
observers so you can imagine starting
with a very simple essentially zero
information condition and creating all
of the wonderful specificity of our
current world just through uh Randomness
happening along the way
so so it's your podcast not mine but you
just brought up the issue that for me is
the most important thing for me and that
is what is Randomness okay what is
probability okay can I say something
about that please no it's it's really
your podcast I'm just the host this is
so this is what drove me into philosophy
I was taking some undergraduate classes
one at three actually one in physics one
in in uh statistics one in history and
the Notions of probability and causation
came up in these classes all the time
and I was asking the teachers what are
you talking about what is probability
anyway and they said uh don't ask me go
to the philosophy I went to the
philosophies and then said you you go
figure that out go to graduate school so
that's what I'm interested in what is
probability and this view about laws
that I told you David Lewis has the
reason it really stuck with me is that I
saw it had the key to the answer of what
probability is if I can describe that
you'll see how it brings together a lot
of what we talked about before remember
how I said before the count of factuals
in Lewis's view are just a way of
talking about the actual facts
laws are too they're just ways of doing
about the actual facts so is probability
probability isn't like a fundamental
feature in the world as an extra thing
what it is is a way that we've
introduced in physics and science to
provide good descriptions in simple way
of a lot of information so if you have
let's say coin tosses many tosses heads
Tails Tails heads Tails Tails headsets
heads Tails sales headed sales and
someone says tell me about that you
might say well first it was a head then
a tail then a tail then a head then tail
and they say I'm getting bored tell me
about it in a simple way and say well
there are a lot of heads and a lot of
tails you say no I want more information
you might for certain sequences be able
to say well
there was heads and tails as the
outcomes of
processes
each with probability a half
and the tosses were independent the
processes were independent of each other
and that would give you a certain a lot
of information about that sequence
um in a very simple succinct
way yeah I think this is what
probability is so Lewis's view about
laws and it's real about
chance come together in a beautiful
beautiful way for me
and in fact for him laws and
probabilities law probabilities always
come together with laws
and if I can say another thing that I
find astonishing in the history of the
subject is that the concept of law was
invented in a certain sense by Descartes
and his friends you know in the middle
of the 17th century in Paris
I'm going to be in Paris this summer I'm
going to want to go to the spot if I can
good and the notion of probability was
also invented in Paris about the same
time
in hacking sites of the year is I think
1654 or something like that by Pascal
who was solving a problem that some
friend of his gave him about how to
settle a a game a gambling game that was
interrupted by the king's soldiers
and he invented how to think about
probability and they were invented about
the same time and they were thought of
as applying to very very different
things
laws to the Motions of the planets and
and pendulum and cannonballs probability
to dice games and then eventually to how
to set in you know insurance policies
for ships going to the new world and and
things like that and and planting
planting
and they were thought to apply to
different domains
although it was thought that God had
something to do with both of them
God was what's pushing the matter around
and then when people ask why is it that
frequencies stabilized you actually find
a few people it's not so widely known
but actually saying it's God that makes
for the stable
they didn't know about independence and
Mathematics then okay they didn't know
the central limit Theory yeah right okay
all right and it wasn't until boltzmann
and Maxwell and later
Einstein and and and and and the
buildings of quantum mechanics brought
probability and laws together and unify
them and I think this is like one of the
most
smacks you in the face interesting
things about the history of science have
you thought about that before it's a
question uh right for you because I did
a little bit of reading when I was
writing from eternity to here you know
those papers uh around boltzmann and
zermello and lo Schmidt and so forth and
but I I'm not up enough to on the
history to really understand the context
of what they had previously thought
before they were faced with statistical
mechanics right so I don't have an
informed opinion about where they were
going I know where they got to I'm not
enough on the history other I have a an
opinion I wouldn't say it's informed I
gave you my opinion I would really like
to talk to somebody who's a really good
historian I have talked to some
historians of Science and basically I
get as well this is complicated that
complicated there's much more written
about the history of probability than
about the history of laws and they're
good things written about that but I
think these have not been written about
together and like I said if there's
someone listening to your podcasts who
takes me up on this I think it's a great
thing and they could write in the
introduction to their book that they
heard about this doing this from love
that okay yeah I'm going dead by then
but I'll still be happy not if they
hurry they could move quickly um look if
so what do you want to say is that
probability is kind of sort of an idea
that we use to describe the actual world
and it's a sensible idea even if things
only happen once right right okay good
that's right and okay because if it's
role in unifying what goes on in the
actual world right so this is gonna once
again a slight diversion but that's okay
because it's really interesting
um
can we think of uh the credences that we
have in different scientific theories
like let's say you know or the axions
the dark matter or are weakly
interacting massive particles the dark
matter is that a matter of a probability
distribution over possible worlds one in
which the axions are dark matter and one
of which it's weakly interacting massive
particles is that a is that a the same
thing so in the probability literature
there's usually a separation between two
ways of thinking about probability one
is probability just in terms of degrees
of credence so degrees of rational
Queens yeah another is probability is
some feature of the world yeah earlier
we were talking about it as a feature of
the world these are not unrelated to
each other because when the world has a
certain feature that it's the
probability of the coin Landing heads is
a half then
uh this this needs a little
qualification but basically that tells
you what rational Credence what rational
degree of beliefs should have in the
next flip of the coin now I don't think
there are objective probabilities like
that for things like scientific theories
like theories about Dark Matter so I do
think this notion of credence about
theories
is applying the notion of credence to
rational credence
Beyond where objective physical
probability applies
I think that's fine I do think it's
really a question about whether you can
talk about rationality in that domain
and where it comes from and of course
there's this whole literature within
philosophy of science uh there are good
ideas about how you should change your
credences that's called Bayesian
updating but where the initial Credence
has come from that you change that's a a
big open question and there are a lot of
philosophers thought about that too
something that logic tells you where
they get them from so John Maynard
Keynes the famous economist had a view
about that Rudolph carnap the famous
philosopher out of you about that
um that those are not my views but those
are views and I don't I shouldn't say
anything more about it because I I'm not
sure what to say well I'm not sure what
to say either but I do have a soft spot
in my heart for a potential unified
account which says there's no objective
probabilities about anything all there
are are credences for different things
happening and it's just that in some
cases where we're sort of more guided
toward what the secretences are like
flipping coins than uh Dark Matter
candidates so I know you have that view
from your views about every everybody in
quantum mechanics but this is a totally
different discussion maybe we'll get
together I I know I'll visit Johns
Hopkins next year
well especially because we're getting to
the punch line here we have the laws of
physics on the table we have the past
hypothesis on the table these are two of
the main ingredients in what you and
David Albert have called the metaculus
uh so explain that a little bit to our
reader our listeners okay since it's
very likely that most of the people who
listen to this have never even run
across the term intactness I should
explain where it comes from yeah and
everybody understands that I why I'm
using this term
here so there's a film by the Cohn
Brothers probably many more people know
about that than about are you David in
my use of this term called a serious man
and in this movie it's about a physicist
who goes to a midlife crisis I assume
you've seen it Sean and maybe you've
even you've experienced the crisis I
don't know about that
okay I'm dealing with maybe you're not
at that point yet I'm not sure but at
any rate
um uh it is a minor character in the
movie who's scribbling in a book it's
clear that this minor character is out
of his mind and somebody asks this minor
character what are you doing and he's
saying he's composing the metaculus and
then he's asked what is that and he says
it's a probability map of the universe
well that's what statistical mechanics
when
when the past hypothesis is added to it
gives you I want to make that clear to
everybody in just a second
when you see that you're given
probabilities of every single sequence
of possible abnormal logically possible
events events that fit in with the laws
that can happen in the universe
okay it's a probability map of the
universe now of course David and I were
perfectly aware
that we were engaged in a little bit of
self-mockery
when we use that term the reason I want
to make that clear is we wrote another
paper about everybody in quantum
mechanics in order to make fun of it
which we call the many Minds the kind of
quantum mechanics and there are people
who went wrote papers taking it
seriously yeah because we didn't say at
the beginning this is in order to show
what's wrong with many whatever you
a lot of those problems that we thought
were wrong have been dealt with
subsequently when we wrote the paper it
was written a long time ago but I am
I want to make that clear to whoever's
listening to this but you do take the
spectacular seriously I mean your idea
is that this is how we should think
given you know our higher level
knowledge of the world about the
probability distribution of everything
that ever happens it's a consequence
that's right let's just make it clear to
the listeners why that's so
what statistical mechanics does is it
signs a probability density or let me
call it distribution over all of the
possible initial conditions of the
universe now of course there's only one
actual initial condition but of all the
possible ones
that probability distribution is the
simplest one possible it's what's called
a little bag it's a kind of uniform
distribution
that will entail together with the
Dynamics the probabilities of everything
all a macroscopic
description of the world is
is a collection of microscopic
descriptions if I say my cat is in the
room
I'm saying what the microscopics state
of the world is it's one of those states
which gets my cat into the room and that
will have a certain probability
so this probability distribution yields
a conditional probability distribution
given such and such a conditions of the
world macroscopic conditions of the
world
these are the probabilities of other
microscopic descriptions of the world
this is deep deep and interesting
because these probabilities should tell
you what your degrees of belief what
your conditional degrees of belief
should be about everything if you only
match them to these what physics gives
you of course we don't know what physics
gives us but what we do do is we learn
about the world in such a way that we do
come up with I think matches that to a
large extent and we can explain why it
does in terms of explaining how we come
up with them and what they are
so I have a little tiny footnote I mean
maybe you said this but I missed it
because you seem to say that there is a
uniform distribution over all the
possible initial conditions but you mean
subject to this past hypothesis that the
Universe started with really really
sorry a very important footnote without
that the whole thing falls apart okay
good okay one other thing about the past
hypothesis although David called it
the past hypothesis that makes it sound
as though he's assuming a distinction
between past and future but a point
that's often neglected even by David I
think even by you but to correct me if
I'm not right is that no no no
what this does is explain what the
difference between past and future is
it's not assuming a distinction between
past and future it's rather by using
this to explain why it is that we can
only influence events in an interesting
way in one temporal Direction but not in
the other why we can have records in one
temporal Direction and not the other why
smoke disperses in one temporal
Direction not the other and so on the
other by explaining why all the times
arrows are oriented in the same
Direction with their tails at the past
hypothesis explaining why that is the
past yeah I never get that wrong that
way I do I completely agree with what
you just said I might sometimes misspeak
but in my mind I know exactly I'm not
sure you really emphasis so I know when
I bought from that yeah maybe that maybe
the students didn't get it right away I
really had to emphasize the students
objective good okay they said well we're
actually assuming the decision past and
future no they're they're they're right
um is the past hypothesis a law in the
same way that uh Einstein's equations is
a law other really good question if you
take David Lewis's view about laws the
answer would be yes because what it does
is by adding it to the system of the
world it's adding a great deal of
information about the world in a very
very simple way
that's I think that argues in favor of
Lewis's view about laws
but isn't it so uh this is an area where
I don't have a firm opinion about this
uh the if I take the definition of
humanism at face value then I get why we
would
be tempted to put the past hypothesis
which is a statement about initial
conditions and the dynamical laws like
Einstein's equation on an equal footing
they're both very very simplified
helpful compact descriptions of what
happens in the world but
they're different also I mean the past
hypothesis is that only one time and
dynamical laws keep being true from
moment to moment so she'll be really
throw them in the same bucket as laws of
nature you just mentioned Einstein one
of the lessons from Einstein is what's
so important about time anyway now I
know that's an exaggeration yeah but
what Einstein did is he stuck time and
space together and I know in series of
quantum gravity there are views in which
what's fundamental it doesn't even
involve space and time they are emergent
features I think they are emergent
depending on whatever it is that
occupies whatever is fun whatever
occupies the fundamental Arena
its distribution is what determines the
dimensionality and the fact that the
dimensions can be divided up in a
particular way and that
um The Divide them in such a way that
there are certain best ways of of
characterizing all of that of
systematizing all of that so another
related question then is why is the past
hypothesis true why is there low entropy
at the big bang and I know that's not
what we're here to uh explain but maybe
you can give me your feelings about is
that even a good question is there a
future answer
philosophical important point to make
about that but this is not a question to
be answered by philosophers in the way
you asked it like I said at the
beginning it's the job of physicist to
tell us about that however somebody
might make the mistake and I know of
some philosophers will have to think
that because I've given a good reason to
think that you means should consider the
past hypothesis to be a law that I've
argued by that that it's a fundamental
law I haven't it might not be a
fundamental law that might be an
explanation it might be that a better
theory of the universe explains why it
is of the past hypothesis is true and I
know that from you know teaching reading
your book on uh that you've come up with
an account that I'm not sure anybody
believes that account does anybody
believe it I think it's simultaneously
the best account out there and nobody
believes it
it's just fair I mean but but I do think
it's a good idea to try to come up with
an account yeah if you can't maybe the
last thing to think to say yeah well
accept it as a fundamental law I'm not
sure that's a physicist yeah no that's
for physicists to do fair enough
division of labor there
um but let's let's get to the payoff
here so what we're gonna do I guess is
use the metaculous picture uh to do
better than Lewis did at coming up with
an explanation for things like uh
causality and stuff like that you know
the way that we use parallel uh possible
World semantics yes
now I wish all of this in my view was a
completed project it's not quite but I
can give you an inkling about how it's
supposed to go so let's go back to
counter factuals
um instead of thinking about similarity
that way let's just think about the
metaculous probability distribution
let's think about the counter factual if
the match has struck what would have
happened
what we're doing there is we're asking
to look at a time when it's somewhat
likely that the match is struck
and then saying if it's at that time
given the macroscopic state of the
universe at that time it's likely
there's a certain
reasonable likelihood the match is
struck
what are the probabilities of various
things happening
well
given the macroscopic state of the
universe at that time that will entail
things in accordance with the metaculous
about what will be going on at later
times including whether there's still
oxygen around whether the match is still
dry or not and so on and so it'll entail
How likely it is that the match will
light or not that's where the truth
conditions the kind of factuals are
going to come from I think that this is
really for me personally now it's just
something that I've just finished so it
hasn't yet been subject to the
incredible you know I don't know
scrutiny and
destructiveness that happens when you
publish a philosophy paper I've been
there but um but um I think this is the
best idea that I've ever come up with
personally I think that this idea Works
to answer all of the questions that
bothered me when I first thinking about
counter factuals as an undergraduate
good so again let me do what I like to
do which is to rephrase it in my own
words to see if I've gotten it so Lewis
had to you know weasel a little bit
about miracles and violating laws of
physics to talk about worlds in which
things were slightly different what you
are able to do with the statistical
mechanical picture is to compare the
macroscopic situation to the microscopic
situation and say oh we don't need to
change the laws of physics we just need
to find a specific microscopic situation
in our macroscopic situation where the
specifics would have gone differently
right where you don't know exactly what
every atom is doing but you don't all
you need to do is change that microstate
to get a in this particular case a
different macro outcome Yes except it's
not a unique microsaid sure because
there'll be a lot of Nyquil says we're
talking about probability distributions
of course as you know if we just talk
about microscopic States compatible with
a macroscopic state there'll be some
microscopic States in which all sorts of
weird things will happen right after
it's you know I might turn into
something that looks like a frog yeah in
the next moment if the molecules are
moving around in a certain
conspiratorial way
um okay so but this is just immensely
unlikely I'm happy to say
um so uh but it's very likely that what
will happen in the situation we describe
is that the the match with light in that
case now what I have done is gotten rid
of Miracles by just limiting
uh kind of factuals to talking about
macroscopic States and that gives rise
to a very deep important question which
isn't dealt with enough by people who
think about statistical mechanics of
what exactly is a macroscopic state yeah
what is it
foreign
do you know the answer really good
question I've been thinking about that I
don't know I know I know what to say if
I stick to thermodynamics
and I know some more to say about it
but here's what I think about it as a
philosopher at the beginning I don't
know the real good answer to this
question yet I'd like to but what I
think of is that well if we think about
all the possible microscopic States
compatible with the worlds I see around
me all those micro all the microscopic
States can be divided up into groups in
all sorts of different ways weirdo ways
well so that one microscopic state which
has me sitting in the room is is in a
collection with a microscopic state that
has I know Joe Biden drinking wine who
knows what okay all sorts of different
things we don't do them in a lot of ways
only certain ways we do it in just
certain ways why some ways rather than
others as I was suggesting earlier I
think the answer that ultimately is
going to have to refer back to us and
our our biology and psychology but how
to fill that in
I don't know the other person I've
talked to a lot and maybe I don't know
if you've done a podcast with them or
not but I know he's written about this
is Carlo Carlo ravelli he was my second
ever podcast guest
I don't know if this came up with him or
not we talked about him
somewhat and uh I know he's thinking
about it too and he's smarter than me so
he may come up with something better
than I could come up with but that's um
you know I think yeah this is a
crucially important question also and
it's the question of emergence right you
know how do we come up with these higher
scale descriptions that work so well
despite the fact that they're not
microscopically complete I am not
actually uh gonna lean on biology or
psychology I think there are
physics-based explanations for this uh
but but I don't have the complete one to
present to the world
I thought that from my satisfaction we
might end on my general philosophical
view which will be about that but if you
wanted to talk about something else
first like free will or or anything we
could do that and then I I'll come back
to that yeah no good let's come back to
that we're we're humming in on the on on
the end here because I think we've we've
covered a lot of ground and some really
good stuff but I just first one this
give you a chance and maybe this is
in the same kind of domain but give a
chance to talk about
emergence and the special Sciences right
this is a a feature of the world that we
know and that the metaculus should have
something to say about I mean why is why
are we able to talk about economics or
psychology uh rather than just saying
everything is physics I guess and I
guess it was Jerry Fodor who first put
things in those words
yeah so your photo was my colleague for
a while and I could say must must the
most fun of my philosophical life was
going from traveling from New York we
both live to uh Rutgers with photo and
listening to him on the the the bus the
reason I say listening to him is that I
could despite what you may think of me
from our conversations I could hardly
ever get a word in edgewise I believe it
yeah
so photo asked this question
why is there anything but physics his
answer was he doesn't think he's going
to find out about the answer to that
until the very day before he finds out
why there's anything at all
the question that came up earlier in our
discussion
um sadly Jerry is no longer with us so I
don't think he ever found out or maybe
wherever he is now he knows the answers
I don't know but in any case I do think
you're right that if everything I said
before the metaculus should say a lot
about the special Sciences in fact if in
fact all of these probabilities of
everything including all of the truths
of the special Sciences already
specified
by the metaculus then whatever
probabilistic laws there are in the
special Sciences must already be in some
sense
I say derivable but I don't really mean
that anybody is ever going to be in
position to derive because they're way
way too complicated but in some sense
they sit upon on top of
the metaculus
um how could they do that well it must
be because they're not adding any
probabilities they must be telling us
what we're conditionalizing on so what
the special Sciences are doing is
they're finding features of the world
such that when we conditionalize on them
we get regularities and other features
of the world that interest us
I think again developing that idea has
not been done by anybody and there are
other philosophers I know of including
people who are students of mine who
disagree with me about this a lot but I
do think it's a very interesting thing
to follow
up on in any
rate
um I do think that in special Sciences
it's more than just finding those
probabilities because special scientists
like to also qualify by interesting
terms like Caterers parabus whatever
that might mean into their special
science regularities I'm not sure looked
at like this special scientists what I'm
saying don't add any laws to the laws of
physics in a certain sense and they
don't add any probabilities to the
probabilities of physics from
statistical mechanics what they do is
they find them and characterize them in
new and interesting ways good yeah I'm
sure
I bet there's occasional uh sociologists
or Economist listening who are not going
to like that uh way of characterizing
what they do for a living but I think
it's exactly right the the relationship
because it's pretty hard to do and they
should get paid a lot if they can do it
I don't think there's anything bad
taking anything bad away from them doing
it but you know if they want to be
physicists they should go be physicists
be sociologists and I mean you've
mentioned it a couple times so let's
let's get it on the table here the Free
Will question you know we've had on the
podcast both people like Robert sapolski
neuroscientist who says there's no such
thing as free will you just doing what
your neurons tell you and they're
programmed by genetics and also Jeanette
and Ismail uh who says though you just
misunderstanding free will it's
completely compatible with the laws of
physics uh I can guess what the answer
is but where do you and the metaculous
come down on questions like this well as
you know Jinan and I are big Pals that
I'm totally with her about this I don't
think my neurons have ever told me
anything I've never even heard my
neurons speak about anything
my my neurons or what's going on when
I'm telling anybody else anything
what I do think is that there are
certain conception of free will
that we've we somehow have and which
particularly philosophers have sort of
put out there which says that whatever
Free Will is it's got to separate us
from everything else that goes on in the
universe from physics I don't think
there is anything like that right so I
think like I said much earlier in the
podcast one of the things that we can do
as philosophers is take our ordinary
Notions and sort of reconcile how we
ordinarily think about things with what
science tells us about things in part by
saying what the ordinary ways are not
quite right but we can come into the
same ballpark we can see why they apply
to the extent they do
by finding something in nearby now I
don't think Jeanette and I are
completely on the same page about how
they do that I think statistical
mechanics and the metaculous is the key
to showing how they do that
I think it does it because if you go
back it's very easy to say give me about
what we're saying about counter factuals
what we're interested in Free Will is
how we can influence why is it that we
can influence the future
but what you can't don't have any
influence over the fast what is it to
influence it's for it to be the case
that's small differences in what's going
on in our brains can make a difference
in one temporal Direction but not the
other
now you might ask the question and the
metaculous answer is that because the
statistical mechanics it says this is a
consequence that small differences in
our brain
will yield the same probabilities for
anything in the past that we care about
while making for big probabilities for
certain things in the future like you
know what you eat for lunch or not
okay but it won't make any difference to
the probabilities of what you ate for
lunch yesterday given the rest of the
macroscopic paths now the reason of
course is because the rest of the
macroscopic best contains records of
what happened what you ate for lunch
yesterday
okay
um there's still a question
of
what what is going on how can we
influence what
differences and what's going on in our
neurons I think the answer is that
that's just what influence is there's
nothing more to it that's how we that's
what we are we are such that
are neurons as such that they make a
difference so what goes on in one
temporal Direction but not the other if
you think of the laws of physics as
something like an iron grip that grips
the states that forces your neurons to
fire one way rather than the other well
good luck to you but that's not how I
think about laws of physics laws of
physics just summarize the whole history
of the world and I think when you think
about it like that you can think about
it being the case that all it is to have
a free choice is for given the
macroscopic state of the world right now
for that to be various microscopic
states that are compatible with that
microscopic State and that's
what it is to be able to make different
choices and it can make a difference in
one temporal Direction but not the other
yeah and so uh the way that I sometimes
put it because the anti-free will people
will try to phrase it as the question
that they would admit you had free will
if you could have acted differently and
then we'll say the laws of physics don't
allow you for you to act differently but
I think the response to that correct me
if I'm wrong is well conditional on what
in conditional on my macroscopic
information of the Universe I could have
acted differently because there are a
lot of microstates that would have led
to different Behavior I didn't go
further conditional on the whole
macroscopic state of the universe right
now right I could have acted differently
not conditional on the exact microscopic
state of the world but uh needless to
say nobody knows what that is and
couldn't know what that is okay good
good we're on the same page okay uh two
final questions one is uh I'm giving you
the uh opportunity to say what you just
wanted to say about your philosophy of
physics and and how deals with okay
macro States
okay so my other hero in the history of
philosophy contemporary philosophy
besides for David Lewis is Hillary
Putnam now Putnam did definitely did go
off this the reservation some of the
time but he was a very deep and
interesting philosopher and I did study
with him a bit not in graduate school
but later on with him I think he was a
really really interesting thinker and he
has a phrase that I really really like
I'm not sure that he meant the same
thing I meant by it but here's his
phrase
he says somebody wanted to know is he a
realist about physics or not
and the the opposition there was between
philosophers who say there's the physics
and it accounts for everything
and there's the mind and somehow the
world is the product of the mind that's
the anti
Putnam said here's his phrase the mind
and the world make up the mind in the
world
if you understand that properly I really
like that here's the why why I like it I
think that my whole conception of laws
is a way that it's in a certain way
human-centric in the sense that it
depends on the fact that human beings
want to get a simple and highly
informative con account of the world
that's other things
maybe aliens aren't like that David
Lewis was worried about this feature of
his world view
oh he gave it a name what did he call it
he give it a nice name he called it
oh [ __ ] sorry that's okay
um
people can look that up
I can't remember it but anyway he had a
nice name for it he thought it was a big
big problem for his view you would love
the name because it's a it's an
Australian bit of slang
took for it anyway his view was his
worry was that his view would be too
subjectivist too much mind dependent
but I don't think it is I think it's
because I think we want the notion of
Science of laws to be mind dependent in
a sense it's not to say that any facts
that the laws say are laws is mind
dependent but it's that they are laws as
mind dependent I do think we want that
because the concept of laws is mind
dependent it's something that we've
concocted in order to account for the
facts so it's not subjectivist or
irreleist in this bad way
okay good so
I I think that's my view there and it's
my view about what's macroscopic what
counts as a macroscopic state too it's
dependent on how we encounter the world
and our psychology ultimately and
fitting us all together in one giant
package is something that I don't know
how to do the view of laws I have though
unsurprisingly it's called the package
deal account of laws and chances
and and fundamental properties because
it turns out that the way I differ with
Lewis is I think also accounts is
fundamental is also going to be part of
this whole package okay and we don't get
into that but we've talked long enough
yeah well okay except I do have one
final question as a bonus dessert treat
for the readers explain I keep saying
readers they're listeners obviously
um why don't you like the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
you're so correct about it all
statistical mechanics and you know what
is this quantum mechanics issue that we
can't quite agree on
so I think there are two big issues by
it
um I think a good place to read about
the problems I don't know whether you've
written in response to it is Tim
maudlin's book on philosophy physics the
quantum mechanics discussion but one of
the problems has been much much
discussed there's going to be a whole
conference about it my guess is you're
one of the people going to the
conference in Israel in October are you
uh I'm busy with a new job so I'm not
going I was invited I can't make it
sorry I'm probably not going to go
either so I was going to go and attack
them anywhere else yeah but I'm just too
busy with dealing with doctors and
things like that yeah but um but anyway
but it'll be a lot about this because
one of your fellow Travelers Lev Weidman
has organized the conference and he's a
big fan and I think that at the end of
the day you can't make use of the way I
understand probability it's driven you
rightly so to take probabilities out of
the world and putting them entirely and
as indexicals applying to indexicles
yeah they saying probabilities I think
that leaves rise to a lot of questions
which really deserves a whole other
podcast and how to think about
indexicality and and so on but I do
believe you were right to take the
problem very seriously and be driven in
that direction that's one of the
problems the other problem is sometimes
I think it's not such a big problem
sometimes I think it is and that is I do
want to ultimately understand how it is
that whatever physics is is fundamental
gives rise to the macroscopic to the
special Sciences to my cat and so on and
when I'm told that the stuff of the
world is what what do you actually think
the stuff of the universe is it must be
something like a what a field it's a
vector
no it's the world is so generous it's
the world but it is mathematically
represented as a vector in Hilbert space
it's some stuff okay can we say
something about that stuff well if it's
represented by a vector
and the the vector is an element in the
Hilbert space but what is the vector the
vector itself does it occupy an arena or
not no
I I mean all the different vectors
occupy Hilbert space that I get right
but the vector itself it has parts does
that Vector well you can divide it up in
different ways you can you can factorize
Hilbert space and then there's a
operational question about how best to
do that which helps you understand where
there are emergent descriptions of
things okay but I want to understand
that emergence a bit better I understand
how it is that atoms banging around can
make for smoke dispersing I want to
understand better how
the fact that this Vector which
represents this sewage generous thing of
the world yeah I don't I don't dislike
that I like that point of doing about it
whatever it is it has an arena part of
the world is an arena some sort of
space-time I'm not sure what its
dimensionality is or anything like that
but I assume it has one
okay
and that somehow whatever's going on in
it
is going to give rise to the Smoke
dispersing
I want to understand that as well as I
understand how it is that
molecules banging around gives rise to
smoke dispersing I'm not giving you an
argument saying it can't be done I'm
just saying I haven't really fully
understood quite how it's done and maybe
it's just my lack of imagination no I
think this is a wonderful research
program for the future that I myself am
engaged in I've written one paper about
it you'll come to Baltimore I'll come to
New York we'll talk about it
okay okay that sounds good to me and
this was great I think that this is a
really great
um way of thinking about
the probability structure of the world
and the importance of it and one of the
great things about it is how many
questions there are still to be answered
there's still a lot of work to be done
by Young natural philosophers out there
yeah it's like one ad thing which didn't
get emphasized earlier is that the the
sort of Louisiana view about
probabilities and laws and the
metaculous way of thinking about
fundamental probabilities fit together
hand and glove because if you think
about the fundamental laws is
deterministic then it becomes very
puzzling as to what in the world
probabilities are but Lewis's account
makes perfectly good sense of those
probabilities there are other ways to do
it too but that's one way to to do it
who says there is no progress in
philosophy yeah I agree there is
something like progress certainly
there's personal progress I can see in
my own life there's definitely a lot of
personal progress I don't know that
someone looking back 200 years from now
will say that but I think they will I I
predict that they will all right Barry
lower thanks very much for being on the
mindscape podcast thank you Sean uh just
before you sign off I can't tell you
just how much you helped me figure out
what I think by asking questions
good that's you know I I that's why I'm
doing this
[Music]
la la la la la
[Music]